so I'm Lee bars I've recently been
appointed as the chair of Clay Cross
Town board um I'm managing director of a
local Clay Cross business I've been
involved in regeneration and development
for the last 30 years as part of my
career I've been a member of the board
for for quite some time now and before
that I was involved in in the the
working
party giving advice based on my
experience of delivery and being
involved in regeneration schemes so um
I'm a clay cross business owner I'm a
Northeast AR bisher resident I'm very
keen to make a difference on my local
[Music]
doorstep I really enjoy being able to
make a difference in my local area I
like to be able able to see um
previously unused spaces become usable
again and provide a
benefit I've worked on many sort of
large scale and local um regeneration
projects so I started off my career in
Brownfield regeneration with doire
County Council working on projects like
Mark and Bale I've worked on Pride Park
similar schemes to to that I've worked
on Manchester Metro Link the uh Second
City Crossing um so I've got a broad
range of
experience I'm used to managing
multi-disciplinary teams to um to
deliver planning applications we we do a
lot of planning in Northeast and and
wider areas so the development process
is um something which is very very
familiar to me and now we're at the
delivery end of the of the project we're
we're trying to get the project through
planning I think my experience will the
key to help Bo sort steer that
[Music]
forward I'm really excited to see the
Clay Cross proposals come forward and be
delivered on the ground I'd like to see
how it can make an enduring lasting
difference to play cross as a town the
businesses there existing businesses
will benefit from creation of this
space
the the difficulties within the role are
are kind of trying to balance everybody
else's sort of slightly different
agendas because whilst we're all as a
board pulling together for a common aim
to successfully deliver the project
everybody has got their own sort of
piece of the project that is obviously
their important part and they've got
their own perspective on how things
should
happen so to be able to listen to those
different views and different
perspectives and then help the board
collectively bring that together for the
common good which is delivering the
project successfully for the benefit of
people of play cross that's the biggest
challenge I
think my previous experience of
delivering multidisciplinary projects
and dealing with different stakeholders
on large scale development I think will
be key to understanding the fact that
people do have different views and
different ways of arriving at the same
at the same conclusion people process
information in different way so it's a
case of um listening and drawing on my
experience from previous
projects so there's a number of
different challenges with with L cross
toown deal there's the um the impact of
how do we move cars around the town
efficiently um there's the impact on
existing in businesses there's the um
fact that the site is sat in a
conservation area so all these factors
have got to be taken into account when
we've been considering the pro proposals
I think the uh that the team have done
an excellent job in balancing the
requirements of all these different
elements and the proposal we've got in
front of us now which is um going to be
considered by planning committee in the
next few months it represents a lot of
hard work and a great scheme moving for
forward the next Milestone is is
achieving Planet once we get past that
then obviously we need to then go out to
Market and and tender The Works once the
um the work has been delivered and this
space is created then play cross has got
a wonderful facility for people to
congregate a place where we can say this
is the this is the center of play cross
on top of that we've got um we've got
the uh low carbon challenge deal which
is reaching out to local businesses to
help them become more energy efficient
and um we've also got the uh the Charlie
Park Redevelopment which again we will
be an excellent facility so I
think it's been a great thing for Clay
Cross I think it'll be proven to be a
great thing for Clay Cross in the future
as well and we'll look back and be very
proud on what we've
delivered
so the the clay crust active scheme has
benefited from 7 million from play cross
town board funding and that really has
gone towards the um the success of the
project and the the early stages now the
we're actually on the ground the
excavation for the the swimming pool is
taking place as we speak so that that
Fund in has been allowed us to um get
that project moving much much sooner
than otherwise we would have been able
to the benefits to play cross residents
are are tangible a new state- of-the-art
facility which provides Leisure
opportunity and fitness opportunity for
the residents I think that would be a
really really positive impact on on the
area and the the New Town Square
creating the opportunity for this
Dynamic day and nighttime economy where
we've got a space where people can
contri congregate and um socialize in in
a nice sort of environment I think it's
a a game changer for L cross as a
evening
[Music]
destination